welcome to the daily climate show coming
up
seven leaders meet in germany amid fears
the climate crisis has been knocked off
the global agenda by the war in ukraine
a new report finds biodiversity could be
damaged beyond repair if the world
doesn't stick to temperature rise
targets
and climate protesters take to the
streets of sydney as australia reveals
the greenhouse gas emissions are still
rising there
world leaders have gathered in germany
for the annual g7 summit but unlike last
year's meeting in cornwall climate
change is not top of the agenda with
russia's invasion of ukraine being the
focus leaders have however spoken of
their continued commitment to the paris
agreement and the glasgow climate pact
aiming to limit the global temperature
rises and reduce the use of fossil fuels
well our europe correspondent siobhan
robbins is at the summit and joins us
live from bavaria
siobhan
why is climate change being overshadowed
so much this year obviously the war but
it's still being talked about
it is still being talked about but as
you say there's been a massive shift
from when this conference was first
planned so when germany announced this
conference it was highly focused on
climate and then russia invaded ukraine
and the focus has switched to the war
that doesn't mean that climate isn't on
the agenda it certainly is along with
other linked uh conversations like
energy security and food shortages but
it has been overshadowed somewhat uh by
the war in ukraine and so today we saw
the g7 countries along with partners who
have been invited here including india
and indonesia reaffirming their
commitments to the paris agreement
saying that they would continue to try
and phase down coal also trying to cut
carbon but i think there are a lot of
questions around some of the statements
that are coming out that one in
particular seems very thin on
information particularly if you
remember the fact that it was india that
was one of the countries that led to
that dilution of the wording at glasgow
around coal so it was meant to be phase
out coal it was then diluted to phase
down coal so questions there and also
actually questions around germany itself
because since the war in ukraine we all
know there's been a big squeeze on
energy supplies and ru and germany was
highly dependent on russia for both gas
and oil now russia has been reducing the
gas it's sending to germany to the point
where a level two gas alert has been
announced here and because of that this
country has started to have to lean back
on coal to help fill the gap but also is
looking at exploring new natural gas and
that's led to criticism of the
chancellor who's hosting this meeting
now he's saying they will still meet
their climate commitments but i've been
speaking to protesters who've been here
every single day of this summit and many
of them are very concerned that climate
justice and climate change have really
slipped down the agenda which cannot be
afforded when it's the world's leading
powers holding these meetings
siobhan robbins thanks for that our
europe correspondent live in bavaria for
us at the g7 now let's get some more of
the day's climate news the japanese
government is asking residents in tokyo
to conserve energy as it warns of
possible power shortages the country is
currently experiencing unusually hot
temperatures with officials saying this
has been the earliest end to the annual
rainy season since records began in
1951.
according to local reports more than 250
people were taken to hospital over the
weekend with heat stroke
10 people have been arrested after at
least 100 climate change protesters
caused chaos across sydney's city center
centre blockade australia members ran
into busy roads and tried to stop peak
hour traffic by dragging bins and
barriers into the middle of the street
the group say they're trying to raise
awareness about climate change and are
calling for further action by leaders
well it comes as australia recorded an
increase in greenhouse gas emissions
last year the country released 488
million metric tons of carbon dioxide
and other gases last year that's up 0.8
from 2020. transport emissions rose 4
and those from agricultural production
also increased australia's newly elected
government pinned the blame on the
previous administration and its inaction
on climate change
now overshooting global temperature rise
targets is likely to cause major and
often irreversible damage to the natural
world that's the finding from a new
study conducted by the university of
cape town and university college london
in 2015 global leaders set a goal of
limiting global warming to well below a
rise of two degrees celsius above
pre-industrial levels but those targets
are just not being met
you can see from the estimate here that
we're already well over one degree of
temperature rises and they could go up
by as much as three and a half degrees
celsius by the end of the century unless
more action is taken to lower emissions
and this new study finds that exceeding
just two degrees is likely to have huge
impacts for biodiversity which will be
difficult to reverse even if
temperatures do eventually decline well
joining us now is one of the reports
authors dr christopher trisos from the
university of cape town dr
thank you very much for joining us could
you describe to us a little bit more
about the actual impact of these
temperature rises on plants and animals
etc
yes thank you for having me so our
research shows that although in an
overshoot scenario people talk about
global heating being reversible so
because of delayed emissions greenhouse
emissions gas cuts global heating would
go above that two degrees threshold and
then carbon dioxide removal technologies
would be used to reverse that
temperature rise so even though the
temperature rise might be reversible in
many places the biodiversity losses
could be permanent such as species going
extinct
so our study looked at communities of
animal species on land and in the oceans
across the earth and found that in many
regions risks to biodiversity from a
global heating overshoot could last
twice as long as the overshoot period
itself so in the scenario we looked at
we would be above 2 degrees celsius for
around 60 years but it would take over a
century
for those pre-overshoot conditions to
return for biodiversity and for almost a
third of animal communities it's
uncertain whether their exposure to
dangerous temperatures would go away
even by the year 2300
and for many ecosystems like coral reefs
or the amazon which is a crucial carbon
storehouse for the planet
this would be expected to lead to
irreversible species losses and
ecosystem degradation
and why will it take species so long to
recover from these temperature rises
so the answer is that for many species
they're very sensitive to temperatures
such as in the tropics they live close
to their thermal thresholds and also in
many parts of the the planet the climate
change that's local is at a different
rate from the global climate change so
when we talk about an overshoot scenario
what policymakers are talking about is
the temperature would go up above some
government
global government agreed threshold like
two degrees celsius and then come back
down but at local scales that return of
temperature might be much slower than
the global average and so for places
like the tropics where many species are
very sensitive to temperatures and these
temperatures could take a long time to
come back down this is a very high risk
strategy so even though we might talk
about overshoot scenarios as bringing
temperatures back down to safe levels or
less dangerous levels what this research
is showing is the journey to get there
could still be very dangerous for
thousands of species globally
dr trisos thank you so much for joining
us today
that is all from us unfortunately you've
been watching the daily climate show
back to you sarah jane